today on the matt well show an
elementary school holds a gay pride
march right through the hallways of the
school plus the confirmation hearings
for judge contanja brown-jackson have
begun and democrats have already made it
clear that any tough questioning of the
judge will automatically be racist and
bigoted also look they would never treat
uh a judge as harshly as republicans are
treating contanja brown jackson also the
daily wire is now selling men's grooming
products like so much of what we do here
it's a it's a joke but also not a joke
at all and i'll explain and the mayor of
boston commemorates st patrick's day by
making racist jokes about white people
also the media tells us about a rise in
adhd among not only children but adults
as well are so many of us suffering from
a mysterious mental illness or could
there be a more logical explanation for
our inability to focus in modern society
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that you're currently on a
phone plan with one of the major
carriers you're helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice causes and candidates common
question i get from my listeners is what
can i do to turn to help turn the tides
in the culture wars is what we talk
about all the time on the show here's a
great first step defund the abortionists
don't let them take your money and use
it to further policies that you don't
believe in switch to charity mobile
today and they will send five percent of
your monthly plan price to any pro-life
charity of your choice charity mobile
offers the latest 5g phones with no
device or service contracts plus great
nationwide coverage
if this sounds like a hassle i assure
you it isn't charity mobile makes
switching your phone from your phone
carrier uh very painless their live
customer service is exceptional they
will guide you through the process and
you can keep your number and your phone
in most cases or if you want you can
take advantage of my special offer and
get a free cell phone with free
activation if you want to take advantage
of all this all you have to do is call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer code walsh join the fight for life
and the fight for children by switching
to charity mobile today
you know it's a scene that somehow isn't
shocking or even mildly surprising
anymore like so many other things in our
culture today what would have been
totally unimaginable just a few years
ago is now totally commonplace latest
example is footage which went viral
yesterday of elementary aged students in
a forced gay pride march through the
hallways of a school now i say this was
a forced march because it's an activity
the school came up with
i'm not sure whether the kids were
allowed to decline participation or not
but even if they were when you're a
small child in the kind of school that
holds gay pride marches in the hallway
even if you're allowed to not
participate you aren't really allowed to
not participate so here's the video
which was proudly posted by an
administrator and then quickly removed
not as proudly but let's watch this
um
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so you see all the kids uh
cycling through there
and these are all these are very young
kids as well that we see
walking down the hallway some of them
seem enthusiastic others not so much but
they're all in the march in the gay
pride march in the hallways of a school
in elementary school and this happened
by the way not in like oregon or
california or vermont or one of those
crazy leftist states but actually texas
dolls elementary school in texas um in
fact is holding a whole week of gay
celebration it's their pride week this
week they call it and it includes many
activities
besides the creepy parade you just saw
there
part of the festivities are things that
the school calls community circles in
which the children will participate in
conversations that as the instructions
make clear
must remain confidential students are
told explicitly that quote what we say
in this room stays in this room
and quote remember to keep what happened
in the circle confidential and um to
make it even creepier they you know
capital t capital c for the circle it's
the circle now if the phrase remember to
keep what happened in the circle
confidential sounds like something you'd
be told at a cult meeting and if what we
say in this room stays in this room
sounds like something that a threat
sounds like maybe like a threat from a
pedophile abuser then you're starting to
understand what our public school system
is and what it's all about
the washington examiner did reach out to
dos elementary to ask about these
secret circles and uh this is what they
were told quote
a spokesperson for the austin
independent school district told the
washington examiner the school the
circles were confidential in the sense
that makes students feel trusted and
respected for their privacy when sharing
in the conversations and that it should
not be misconstrued to mean don't tell
your parents
circles are part of social emotional
learning and are used for a variety of
speaking topics such as test anxiety
world events internal conflict
resolution social justice uh the
spokesperson said and the conversation
template allows for a process and gives
everyone an option an optional
opportunity to speak everyone not just
parents has access to the materials
ahead of time every parent has the right
to opt out of these activities
oh they give you the old opt out like
once again that's that's like opting out
of the gay pride march when you're you
know a seven-year-old at one of these
schools
yeah you could you could technically opt
out but there's a lot of social
authorization that comes with that and
also they're making it clear implicitly
and probably explicitly that if you're
not participating in all this kind of
stuff then you're a bigot
so now this would what you just heard
there would already be a dubious excuse
even if you were predisposed to trust
what schools tell you
but if you've been paying attention at
all you do not trust the schools at all
and so the assurances they give about
their secret gay pride circle meetings
will mean nothing to you at all
and it shouldn't mean anything to you
because the schools are just as they
appear and so often act
abusive cult indoctrination centers
they are what you might call alternative
reality generators now i've said before
that the news media are i would dub them
reality curators so they take little
bits of what's happening in the world
they cut out the parts they don't want
you to see
and they and oftentimes they will ban
you from talking about those things they
don't want you to see like what happened
with the new york post and hunter
biden's laptop and all the parts they
want you to see they assemble them into
the picture that they they want to
present to you um they operate according
to a kind of
ideologically driven algorithm and when
you're listening to the news media
that's really what you're what you're
getting that you're getting an algorithm
the actual algorithms on social media
are also ideologically driven of course
in order to skew your perception of the
world in reality itself
the schools though because they get the
kids at such a young age and have them
for so long with hours every day of
uninterrupted indoctrination
opportunities
they go even deeper they create an
entire alternate reality and after years
of that you end up with the sorts of
college kids that i encounter many of us
have seen protesting and so on
who seem like you know they're from some
sort of
other dimension really they seem like
beings from another dimension
they live in a world that has almost no
connection to the real world
that's why the left gets away with
propaganda campaigns that are so
blatantly false as to at first seem
almost farcical
for example yesterday kim mangoni who's
a
failed politician in california
tweeted a picture of a billboard with
the word gay on it that's all it says
just says gay and she captioned the the
tweet how many of these billboards do
you want me to put up uh in florida it's
just you know just just as gay it's all
says this is obviously supposed to be in
protest of the so-called don't say gay
bill now my suggestion is that she put
up one billboard
for every time the word gay appears in
the legislation itself which of course
means she's not going to be putting up
any billboards at all
because the word is not in the
legislation
but the fact that the word doesn't
appear in the legislation itself and
that the don't say gay bill is a total
fabrication of the left
doesn't matter
their strategy is very simple
they don't like the florida parental
rights bill but they can't argue against
it without sounding like a bunch of
perverted freaks so instead they
completely invent a different bill out
of thin air
and argue against that instead
they get away with it
you know
more than get away with in fact they
often win with this exact strategy
because they run all the institutions
and because
they keep society supplied with a
never-ending stream of people whose
minds and souls exist in a fictional
universe a universe the left creates now
the good news i guess
in a way
is that the people in charge of this
indoctrination are very stupid
um as the left increasingly prioritizes
ideological conformity over anything
else
also the quality of what they produce
has gone down and the quality of the
people who are in charge of the
indoctrination has gone down this is why
most hollywood movies these days
are so terrible um hollywood of course
has been liberal for a long time but it
used to
you know used to hire the most talented
people to tell compelling stories and
the stories would often happen to have a
liberal bent because that was the world
view of the people telling the stories
now they don't hire the most talented
people their first second and third
priority is to fill their diversity
quotas and make films and shows that
advertise their leftist purity
this means that what they make is more
intensely ideological than it's ever
been but also that the quality is worse
than it's ever been
the bright side of that is that the
indoctrination is less effective
the more that the indoctrination is the
primary goal
christian movies on the other end of the
spectrum have long had this exact same
problem now their message is actually
good so that's the key difference and
it's an important difference
but all the films you know in the
christian movie industry care about is
the message they don't care about
telling good stories or telling them
well or having a good script good acting
it's like they consider all that to be
secondary
and so they are far less effective at
getting their message across because the
movies are bad
now
we see something like this in the school
too where many of the people teaching
our kids um
are indoctrinators and groomers of
course and also extremely stupid case in
point two middle school counselors in
oregon uh were mad this week that they
couldn't fly their gay pride and blm
flags in school
so they recorded this tick-tock video in
their counseling office
in uh in protest watch
[Music]
[Music]
okay now you have to appreciate these
two ladies flipping off the camera in
front of a flag that says be kind to all
uh you also have to appreciate the
caption on the video which misspells the
word aloud and somehow that manages to
be you know the most outrageous aspect
of that video there
these are very dumb people with no
discernible skills or abilities and
double-digit iqs at best
um in many such cases in the school
system
but they don't need to be effective
indoctrinators really
because unlike hollywood and media and
all the other institutions
who are
less effective in indoctrination when
their quality goes down
in this case the school system they have
your kids
for so many years and so many hours in a
day that it becomes a sort of war of
attrition with your child's soul with
your child's mind
they just keep pushing until they wear
their victims down and have them firmly
in their clutches
but
there is a kind of
easy solution if not easy than at least
simple which is get your kids out of the
system
and keep them
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know with the ever increasing
numbers of car makes and models it's now
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
um you have but you don't need to this
is the good news because you have
computers at home with access to
rockauto.com you probably carry one
around your pocket all the time all you
got to do is pull it out go to
rockauto.com why should you choose to
spend
30 50 100 more
for the exact same auto parts at a chain
store or new car dealership no example
uh no reason to do that for example a uh
delphi fg
1456 fuel pump assembly for 2005
2005-2010 honda odyssey is normally 353
at advance which is a big chain store
but it's 216
at rockauto.com and i know exactly what
i just read they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet whether it's from your for your
classic or daily driver you can get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers so go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck right walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you
um all right i have to talk about this
at the top i you know i'm really a kind
of a loss here i feel betrayed
heartbroken
confused
yesterday i'm at work in my office
you know and i'm and i'm here i'm at
work i'm doing important work
you know trying to figure out what i'm
going to talk about on my podcast very
important work and i get a text from my
wife and it says this is what it says
this is my wife
she says left my shopping cart in the
parking lot
just like that there's no other nothing
this just that she decided to send that
to me and i text her back and i said uh
why what possible excuse could you have
you know how important this issue is to
me and her response lol
this is actually a form of just like
psychological terrorism committed by my
wife against me callously for no reason
other than
her own amusement i guess
and when i talk to her about it later
you know more extensively because it's
like this is the kind of thing okay
we're gonna talk about this when i get
home we're having a conversation about
this
and and then she she actually tried to
hit me with the um i mean she didn't try
to physically hit me she tried to hit me
with the excuse that she you know she
had uh
our daughter two-year-old with her emma
and you know the two-year-old was was
having a meltdown and so she wasn't
don't get this is me you're talking to
you don't think i've heard that excuse
before
the child's crying and so you can't walk
20 feet and put the card away
this is what i have to deal with
every day um
all right let's uh we'll go here the
first day of the senate judiciary
committee hearings for kantanji brown
jackson started yesterday and right out
of the gate yesterday
um democrats of course laid down the
racism gauntlet as you'd expect them to
do and made it very clear that that any
difficult questioning that may follow by
republicans is racist and keep something
in mind about about democrats of course
now
they said that
justice kavanaugh was the ringleader of
a gang of cyril rapists they said that
amy coney barrett was the
you know a member of a of a handmaid's
tale secret cult
um otherwise known as just she was just
catholic she's in the catholic church
so but
but but they they really feel strongly
that you should treat um supreme court
nominees with respect and dignity
you want to be very clear about that
so cory cory booker came out of the gate
with this and
made sure to highlight
just how
he took a sort of a more passively
passive aggressive approach
rather than explicitly saying if you
criticize her you're a racist which i'm
sure he will say and probably has
already said but here he decided to you
know just highlight how historic and
wonderful all of this is and how could
anyone do anything but squeal with
delight at the very thought of contanji
brown jackson on the supreme court let's
listen
when you were in my office uh you were
focused on the hearings and a lot of the
substance that had such great questions
i could not stop being just joyous that
you were sitting in my office and i
couldn't stop bringing up to you the
historical nature of this forgive me i
grew up in a small black church where i
was taught to make a joyous noise unto
the lord and this is not a normal day
for america we have never had this
moment before
and i just want to talk about the joy
well cory booker makes joyous noises i
don't really want to know what
booker's
joyous noises sound like that's
something he should keep to himself in
his private life but you know the point
is very clear not very subtle at all
that this is a what a what a wonderful
historic moment um yeah i mean
we've had black supreme court justices
before but uh but they don't really
count especially claire's thomas he
doesn't count obviously
so this is what what can it all we
should be doing is cory according to
cory brooker we should all just be
singing
songs of praise that's what the that's
what the supreme court confirmation
hearing should consist of is that
everybody locking arms together holding
hands and singing
joyously to the lord before contanji
brown jackson
now maisie hirono was a little bit more
direct with the racism blackmail let's
listen to what she had to say
so my republican colleagues and public
figures have attempted to undermine your
qualifications through their pejorative
use of the term affordable
affirmative action
i mean they haven't posted there
no it's not republicans it's not
republicans who
uh who said that contagion brown jackson
was selected
at least in part
because of her skin color her gender
republicans didn't say that that was
that was joe biden who said that it was
joe biden who announced that to begin
with that he is already ahead of time
before he ever said kataji brown
jackson's name i mean like a year before
or more than a year before he ever even
said her name he said
i've whittled it all down i'm excluding
everybody who is not a black woman
they're the only ones i'm going to
consider and then there's the other part
of that which he didn't say which is
that i'm only considering leftist black
women so it's a it's a a whittled down
much more limited pool of people
and all we really know is that kantanji
brown jackson was allegedly the most
qualified one
in that group
was she the most qualified one
among all potential candidates well we
have no idea because joe biden according
to himself
did not consider any of the other ones
so just to clarify that but let's keep
listening to mesa toronto for some
reason they're solely nominated due to
your race and not for other factors
apparently some have even claimed that
you need to show your lsat scores
to determine whether you are a top legal
mind this is incredibly offensive and
condescending
let me be clear your nomination is about
not about filling a quota
it is about time
it's about time that we have a highly
qualified highly accomplished black
woman on the supreme court it's about
time our highest court better reflects
the country it serves
it's about time that black women and
girls across the country can finally see
themselves who look like them sitting
on the highest court making decisions
that it will impact
their lives
so may zero of course has set it up
along with all the other democrats and
it was all it was all very similar to
that
all right i also can't think of an
excuse for this as we move
up to boston where mayor michelle wu she
may remember her she was last seen sort
of awkwardly sitting there silently
while she got insulted relentlessly on
instagram live which was a great a great
a great video this one
not as good she gave a speech at the
annual boston st patrick's day breakfast
where she said this listen
over 100 days we have connected unhoused
residents at mass and cast to housing
treatment and services
we've launched three free bus lines
we've taken some big bold actions but i
won't lie
this past winter was pretty intense
trial by snow
trial by fire fighters union
i'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and white
i'm talking about snowflakes snowflakes
i mean snowstorm snowflakes
oh hilarious she's dealing with problems
that are expensive disruptive and white
which is a joke she decided to tell by
the way at a st patrick's day event
and the excuse that's being given
on her behalf is that
uh apparently at this event the
tradition is that the mayor gets up
there and gives a funny speech and tells
a bunch of jokes
okay fine
so
she's telling a joke now now all of a
sudden people on the left are saying
calm down it's just a joke
now when when an actual stand-up
comedian
at a stand-up special tells jokes
that's uh that that's that's
armageddon that's in a that's the
apocalypse that's a human rights abuse
we gotta have marches in the street and
boycotts
you know dave chappelle's an actual
stand-up comedian it's his job to tell
jokes
and he does a stand-up special where he
tells jokes
and that's a problem you can't do that
yeah we're going to make excuses for a
politician on st patrick's day
who decides to make a joke that all of
her problems are expensive disruptive
and white
now i don't need to point this out but i
will because there's a yeah that's
pretty much the entire show is me
pointing out things i should need to
point out um
if this was
a mayor of a city
who was commemorating black history
month
by making a hilarious joke about how
most of his problems are expensive
disruptive and black
you know i don't think all the the
people that are
having such good humor about it would
feel that way but there would be riots
in the streets
it would be considered a historic
catastrophe they would build i mean they
would
literally commemorate the day that it
happened
if that happened today march 22nd then a
mayor got up there and said you know all
my problems are descriptive
expensive disruptive and black
i'm not talking about black people i'm
talking about uh the pavement there's a
lot of potholes don't you get it
if that were to happen
and it march 22nd march 22nd would be a
day they would have we would have
anniversaries of it next march 22nd they
would talk about the where they were
when they heard that joke and what what
terrible damage it did to them the
trauma that they've suffered i mean we
would never hear the end of it
they would build monuments to
commemorate the tragedy where people
could go and weep over the joke that was
told
and yet
what we are supposed to get accustomed
to and many of us are accustomed to is
just that
you know it's different
mayor wu is a non-white person and she's
making jokes about white people
and so it's just different she's allowed
to do that
that's what we're supposed to accept
that i i don't i think we should not
accept it now
as i've said before
we don't want to call this a double
standard really because it's actually
it's actually not
there is there is in fact one standard
the standard is
from from the left like we can do things
that you can't do
non-white people can do things that
white that white people cannot do that's
that's the standard
but it's a twisted perverse
standard
and we should never tire of criticizing
of it
and yes we should
uh react
with anger to stuff like this we should
be outraged about it yeah
because the only other option is just to
move on from it and say okay fine you
can do that
like i know you're doing something
that a white person could never get away
with but all right you can just do it
why should we go along with that
that's the worst it's like as as white
people you're just supposed to sort of
accept that okay well you can come and
spit in my face
all right
i don't like it but uh all right
why should we accept that
no i'm not gonna have you spit in my
face especially it's like st patrick's
day
to make it all the worse
so this is your way rather than talking
about how you appreciate irish culture
you're going to tell us that your your
problems are all white
you disgusting
drooling ugly
bigot you racist
scumbag that should be the response to
this person
it is because it that's exactly what it
would be in the reverse but a lot a lot
more harshly we all know i mean they
would i mean the person would be the
mayor would be would be kicked out of
office
probably arrested for a hate crime and
i'm not exaggerating
but you can't even you can't conceive
you can't even conceive of actually
fully of what the reaction would be
because it because because it is
literally inconceivable that a
politician would ever make a joke like
that
about any race of people other than
white and is that a reality that we want
to accept
that there is one race of people that
the most powerful people in our society
politicians who are running cities and
running the country are allowed to joke
about an insult do we really want to
accept that because that doesn't go
anywhere good
when there's one group of people that we
determine by race who you're allowed to
disrespect but nobody else
now you want to open up the floodgates
and say that yeah jokes or jokes you
make jokes about any race you want
and uh hey you know that's fine
if that's the rule i'm totally on board
for that
but i'm not on board for the rule that
you're that you're allowed to to do this
to white people but nobody else not on
board for that
all right uh what else we got
from the post-millennial it says it's
been reported that staff from an unnamed
uk hospital told local police last year
that a sexual assault they were
investigating could not have happened
because patients are placed on
single-sex wards per the guidelines of
the national health service the alleged
attacker was a attacker was a biological
male who self-identifies as a woman was
therefore counted to be of the same sex
as the woman who the whom the biological
male is alleged to have raped
quote they forgot that there was cctv
nurses and observers noted baroness
nicholson um during a parliamentary
debate in the house of lords on the
issue of the same-sex wars which are the
standard in the area
um
staff told police a year ago that there
were no males present on the ward at the
time of the attack and as the result the
rape could not have occurred
but it turns out that there was a male
so
uh the alleged rape of a woman by a male
and
it was covered up
and the police were told oh there's a
well there's no there's no males here
there's no men
couldn't have happened
now what you should know is okay this is
happening in same-sex wards at hospitals
in the uk
and i'm sure this is not the first such
occurrence it's also happening i mean
this is very common in women's prisons
very common quite sure that
we we hear you hear stories
okay we have heard we have heard of some
specific cases of it happening
but this is mostly a silent epidemic
because
at least you know in a hospital
you're not there against your will most
of the time
and so women who fall victim
are fortunately going to be able to
speak out you know and are going to be
able to call attention to what happened
to them and other people at the hospital
because which is exactly what happened
here
now in a women's prison though
the women are there they can't leave and
so they have no really they have no real
way of of getting the word out about
what happened to them
and they're they're they're
you know in an environment
where they could face severe
consequences for speaking out if the
people running the prison don't want
them to
um so this is a mostly silent epidemic
in women's prisons
and the reason why the reason i know the
reason i can guarantee that this is
happening a lot in women's prisons is
because one because of the of the cases
that we've heard and the thing is
you know
anytime you hear cases of something like
this if there's a if there's a problem
of sexual abuse inside an institution
and you hear some of the cases you
already know but you're not going to
hear about every case
and so however however many you heard
about you can multiply that by five at
least
but then in a prison i don't know
multiply it by 10 by 20
given how difficult it is for the
victims to
um
reveal what's happening to them
and the other way that i know that it's
happening is that it's is that i i know
it's a fact
that in many states in this country they
are putting
male
violent
male offenders including sex offenders
in cells with women
and it is just a guarantee that you're
going to have a mass epidemic of women
getting raped if you do that it's a
guarantee it's not a maybe it's a
guarantee
um so this is
whether or not the
the lid is ever really blown off and we
we find out
you know the full extent of the epidemic
i don't know
but it is happening
also this on the transition i just want
to play this a a a little bit of this
probably not the whole thing but a
rapper named uh
who's this lil boozy
who
i'm sure is a great musician but he was
being interviewed
um on a show and he was asked about the
uh issue of of men playing women's
sports and let's listen to what a little
bit about what this this guy had to say
i i personally don't think that uh it's
fair
for not trans in a minute for a male 1
male trans athlete to to compete in
women's sports because he
yeah let them women have their glory man
yeah we let that go down in five ten
years they're gonna have kids raising
their churn to be big strong mother
then turn into women and take over the
sport and get million dollar contracts
watch
well i mean if you think about women's
sports really think much like money
mothers think
yeah go get a 7-5
a 7-5 and turn into a woman
and put him on the ncaa team
and i'm dunking like [ __ ]
y'all me it's this world i ain't
happening
no i feel bad cause you know
at the end of the day women's sports in
general i feel have always had an uphill
battle compare compared to the male
sports women don't get paid like me uh i
kind of wish you would play the entire
clip because it's great but i can't
really justify it's two and a half
minutes long but you can go on online
and find it i look he he this
little boozy if i may say um as as is
the case on so many other issues i'm
sure but but on this he is making more
sense than than almost any college
professor that's spoken out people in
media
you know
um
he's making more sense than any of them
when it comes to the issue of the
differences between men and women and
should men participate in little sports
in women's sports i i would i would go
to lil boozy as an authority before i'd
go to any like gender studies professor
anything i mean in a second i would go
to him
because this is just this is just basic
common sense
and this is where it gives you a little
bit of
a little glimmer of
of hope perhaps
that with the women's sports issue in
particular and this is one of the
reasons why i have focused on it so much
even though as i've said a million times
it is it's just one battlefield it's one
area like the actual wars for truth and
reality itself and this is just one
battlefield in that fight but it's an
important battlefield
because it can be kind of a you know an
awakening moment for a lot of people
you know a lot of people kind of live
their lives and they're either they're
not aware
of what's happening out there they don't
think sort of
uh they're not they're not thinking much
in the abstract about about gender
ideology and what it could mean
they're just kind of living their lives
and then
when this stuff
kind of
starts
manifesting itself in the real world
and impacting people's real lives that's
when it becomes an awakening moment for
a lot of just regular sort of common
sense people
and so was this
you know leah thomas competing against
the women in the ncaa women's swimming
championship
what was this a bridge too far you know
is the left
getting too greedy i mean that we know
that they're greedy and they're never
satisfied
and they're always they're always trying
to surge forward
that's why we call them progressive
they're always progressing but they
progress like a like a a tumor
progresses okay
um
and we know that they're always doing
that but do they go too far too fast
because usually they want to lay the
groundwork indoctrinate people what we
talked about at the beginning especially
in the school system but the medium and
all these institutions indoctrinating
people getting getting them ready for
the next step in the progression uh did
they overshoot the target here
uh get the cart in front of the horse
whatever metaphor you want to use i
don't know
i mean even if they did it doesn't mean
that we can just declare victory look at
that we won this battle but but uh it
could have been a misstep miscalculation
and it's awakened just normal common
sense people to say well this doesn't
make any sense
all right
next what i have to of course mention
this we today at the daily wire unveiled
our new product which we're now getting
into the men's grooming game with
jeremy's razors uh of course the god
king jeremy bourne with his own razor
line now i i will say
i'm uh
normally i would say that i'm i'm
ethically
philosophically opposed to shaving in
general as is clear from my appearance
um but even i will say that these are
high quality razors which we'll get into
the back story of this but some of that
comes out in the in the the ad that we
put together for this
high quality razors with a with an add
that reflects the quality of the razors
let's
let's play that for you now
[Music]
do you remember when there were two
genders and only one and a half of them
had to shave their mustaches
oh hi i'm jeremy boring ceo and god king
of the daily wire harry's razors used to
advertise on our shows they're a great
product and we were happy to do it
that's before some peon who works for me
went and said that boys are boys and
girls or girls and that was just too
much for harry's
they condemned our views views held by
millions of americans and virtually
every human who's walked the planet
until about 15 minutes ago as
inexcusable and they dropped their ads
from our network because of what they
called values misalignment
you're damn right our values are
misaligned and it's not just harry's
either gillette razors used to be the
best a man could get
then they decided that men are too toxic
unless you're the kind of man who
teaches his daughter to shave her beard
if that makes sense to you keep buying
gillette
but if you've had enough of the woke
bull
and you're tired of paying companies
like harry's and gillette to hate you
[Music]
can buy my new razor instead
behold jeremy's razors yes they're real
yes they're fabulous
but jeremy you say you're a stealth
silver fox with a salt and pepper beard
that's the envy of lesser men
you're damn right i am
and i want to be clear that shaving with
the jeremy's razor won't actually make
you look more like me
you're giving me power
could make you look more like this guy
though
and that's the most homoerotic moment
you'll ever get from a jeremy's razor
commercial
what kind of man shaves with a jeremy's
razor
i don't know how about cowboys
firefighters those guys have shot osama
bin laden
i mean no none of those guys have ever
even heard of a jeremy's razor but
but imagine how much more manly they'd
be if they had
[Applause]
right now
you're probably wondering if this whole
thing is a joke
sure it is that doesn't mean it isn't
real or that it won't be the best shave
of your life
harry's razors doesn't want your
business i do
they seem to hate you and i
well i can't say that i love you but i
don't mean you any specific harm
[Music]
our country's in trouble conservatives
are being cancelled by hollywood the
media universities and now harry's
razors stop giving your money to woke
corporations who don't think you deserve
their product
give it to me instead
[Music]
head over to ihateharris.com and
pre-order your founders series razer and
shaving cream set today
[Music]
yeah i have to say i'm it's a great ad i
am very upset that we had a flamethrower
here at the office apparently and i was
not given a chance to play with it at
all but i guess you know safety concerns
um i love the whole ad i thought
my favorite part was if i had and i'm
and i'm just not playing favorites at
all not not biased at all but um
we did get a glimpse of the best-selling
most acclaimed lgbt children's book of
all time which you can get at
johnnywalrus.com so that was a great
moment as well um
but this is we have to keep in mind as
it says in the end
harry's
you know we had been advertising with
them
they decided to pull all their ads
not even because there was some
coordinated campaign where they were
getting all kinds of pressure from all
over the place but as is so often the
case
it's a small minority of people and in
this case now we've seen small
minorities
imposing their will on major
corporations we've seen that it is we're
seeing it right now disney we've seen it
at netflix we've seen it many places in
this case it was one
anonymous twitter account with two
followers
who nobody is paying attention to nobody
cares and all they did was just send a
tweet out to harry's saying uh as you
know michael knowles thinks that uh
you know men are men and women are women
that's that's all that knowledge really
said
and just because of that harry said well
okay we'll pull all our advertisements
this is a profitable arrangement for for
harry's just because of that one person
that you want to talk about privilege
that's the privilege you have that is
the ideal so much of the privilege in
this country is ideologically
defined
and that's the privilege you have as a
leftist
conservatives don't have that kind of
privilege
because the left runs all the
institutions and they make all the
products
and that's why
you know the razors here it's it's a
like so much of what we do it's a it's a
joke because it's funny and it's a troll
and we um we put a lot of effort into
very elaborate trolling at this company
which is one of the reasons why i like
working here and i appreciate it as a as
a troll you know at heart myself but
it's also a lot of being a joke it's
also very also very serious thing
which is that
you know when this happens we've gotten
used to this with companies
where they
they announce that's what harry's did it
wasn't just they pulled the ads
they
announced that uh they don't want
anything to do with us
we're bigots we're this and that we're
we have inexcusable values which is an
attack not just on us but obviously on
all of
everybody in the audience
because what they're implicitly saying
is well what all you people
and why do you
why are you still watching and listening
to all this bigoted material with these
inexecuted you must have the inexcusable
values too so we had these companies
that they come out and and announce like
we don't want your business we hate you
we we oppose everything that you stand
for
on a real fundamental level too
and usually what happens is they
companies do this
and then we on the right we complain
about it and we whine about it and we
talk about cancel culture
and then maybe we organize a boycott
most the time we don't even do that but
even if we do the boycott it lasts for
like a week if it makes it that long and
it has no effect at all
doesn't matter
the company doesn't feel the pain at all
and then we just go back to normal go
back to using those products
and part of the reason that happens is
because
you know in a way it's like you almost
don't don't have a choice with some of
this stuff you you have to buy things
you need razors you need you know you
need basic things like that
unless you're going to go shave with a
butcher's knife or something you need
some kind of grooming product if you are
if you are going to shave at all which i
wouldn't recommend but if you do
so partly out of necessity we go back we
start using these products again which
is why the daily wire we've decided well
let's make our own products just like
we're making our own entertainment
rather than complaining that
entertainment is increasingly
ideologically
biased in the extreme
we'll make our own
you know and if you want to
make a statement
that's the way that you do it
if you want to more than making a
statement actually have a chance at
winning
winning the culture war that's how you
do it
we'll just do it ourselves make our own
products make our own things
and that's what we're doing let's get
now to the comment section
do you know their name
erica says matt i've always wondered why
you refer to transgender people by their
chosen name and not their given name i
feel like it's confusing to call a man
leah or caitlyn and i'm just wondering
why you respect the chosen names i
personally refer to bruce jenner and
will thomas as such but i do frequently
wonder what the right thing to do in
that situation is well
um the answer is simply because names
are arbitrary and you can legally be
whatever name you want to be so it's got
nothing to do with respect um a name is
not a biological reality
lots of people have names that i think
are dumb but they're still their name so
if will thomas and i don't know if he
did or not but i i don't know that he
didn't do it if will thomas legally
changes his name to leah then
that's his name it doesn't make sense
for me to say oh no your name is really
will
it doesn't make any more sense than for
someone comes along and says my name is
fred and i say i don't like that name
your name is really you know bill it
just doesn't make any
sense it's not about being disrespectful
it's just about not making any sense
because you can actually have whatever
name you want even if it's a really
stupid name
you can still do that
um
because names again are not biological
realities they are
they are in fact human constructs and
names can also change i mean there was a
time when men were named ashley and now
no men are just like it can change over
time
um
now so if a man says that i i'm gonna
change my name and make it leah well i
think that's dumb
because that is a girl's name but you
you can have that name if you want i
can't tell you that that's not your name
but you're still a man okay so that's
the part that doesn't change and that's
the point and this is an important
distinction i think because your sex is
not like your name at all and i don't
want to compare the two i think you do
the transgender agenda actually a favor
by equating the two they are not the
same
um because your sex unlike your name is
not something you can choose you can
choose a name for yourself legally
you can't do that with your sex
names are also assigned you want to talk
with something that's assigned at birth
your name is assigned at birth and you
can actually as you get older look and
say to yourself i don't really like the
name that i was assigned i'll pick a new
one and you can do that
your sex though is not assigned at birth
it is observed it's noted by the doctor
and that's just your sex you can never
change it
um so it's not because i'm worried about
respecting thomas or whatever i don't
respect him at all
um
it's because i i want to make sure that
i'm i'm being as clear as possible
all right ian byrne says can the ally
ship be be the first ship sent by elon
to mars
i'm on board with that plan
ship them all off there uh redemption
happens says here again matt being
clueless as to the effects of execution
on prison staff you want to turn those
officers into killers and you cluelessly
omit the fact that a lot of these guys
have guilt and shame because many of
them are even saying that drug laws are
bs and now you want to add ptsd on top
of that
the average life expectancy for
corrections officer is only 55 for a
reason genius
well actually disregarding your
condescending tone there i think that um
the psychological effect of the people
administering capital punishment is in
fact the best argument against capital
punishment it's not used very often i
mean usually when people are arguing
against capital punishment they're going
with different
lines of argument but i think that this
is the most compelling one
um and for a long time i was
anti-capital punishment for this very
reason this was the thing that i
couldn't quite get over
is that if you're having capital
punishment
you are
asking requiring
somebody to do this which is to kill and
kill a defenseless person
and the convict after they've been
convicted i mean they are defense
they're not innocent but they are
defenseless
you're not you're not killing them
directly in self-defense they're not
threatening to kill you and you kill
them
um
so the question is
as a civilized society
can we ask people to do that and i've
ultimately come down to the answer of
yes we can i think it's a necessity
this is something that we need in
society and so we need people to do it
now we don't we don't force anyone to do
it it's not like we're choosing people
at random and saying you're going to be
the
death chamber executioners
but if you get into this line of work
then this is your job and it is uh
you're doing something
noble you're doing something that this
is justice you're administering justice
is there a psychological effect
for sure
um
a uh
a quite significant one
but it's still something that needs to
be done so although i understand the
argument i don't think it i don't think
it overcomes the need for justice in
society and the fact that there are
things people can do that are so heinous
so egregious so outside the bounds of
anything that can be considered
acceptable human behavior that we have
no choice as a society but to
inflict upon them the ultimate
punishment
um and also by the way we were talking
about firing squad the firing squad
actually addresses some of the problems
you're talking about i mean if you
stretch strap somebody down to a gurney
or put them in a
electric chair somebody still needs to
flip the switch or or
administer the needle
with a firing squad
you know you have multiple people firing
and some of them have blanks and that
way none of them really know exactly
who's the one who fired the uh the fatal
shot
so i actually think the firing squad
is a an even better
uh method
for this exact reason
um
let's see
lee says i can't believe i'm still
hearing conservatives call for outlawing
marriage gay marriage in 2022.
oh yeah the old current year thing first
of all the date on the calendar has no
bearing on fundamental principles second
i'm not arguing for outlaw and gay
marriage i'm arguing that gay marriage
is a contradiction in terms like it
can't exist because marriage is a
certain thing with a certain function a
certain definition that's the argument
um that's that's been the argument all
along in defense of what we now call
so-called traditional marriage but i
would say that saying traditional
marriage is like it's like saying
biological sex or your biological male
you don't need the biological because
there's only one kind of male which is
biological male and there's only one
kind of actual marriage which is what we
now call the traditional marriage
because marriage again is a certain
thing it's an institution with a certain
purpose and it serves a certain function
and the thing is the people who came
along and said
no marriage is not that
you know they they the activists said uh
no no marriage is not that it doesn't
serve the fundamental purpose of being
the foundation for the nuclear family
it's not that you're wrong about that uh
it's what everyone thought throughout
all of history basically but you're
wrong about that and they said that
but they never supplied a new definition
they never said okay well if marriage
isn't that then what is it why do we
have it
you might not have liked the answer
before but at least there was an answer
now there's no answer it's yet another
thing that the left comes along
um and says takes up takes a a word or a
foundational concept
for human society and says oh no we're
changing this
but when they change it they just remove
the meaning from it and do not even
supply a new meaning
now it's just it's just nothing marriage
is like nothing now
um and finally says uh
matt i can't understand why you would
oppose surrogacy for everyone so people
who can't have kids are just out of luck
well you know i explain why um first of
all if a man and woman are married and
can't have kids there's there's always
adoption you know if
man and woman
can't have kids i think um
still pursuing parenthood is a is a very
good thing to do
and uh there are lots of children that
need to be adopted so no they aren't out
of luck as you say
but also another important point
important point here is that nobody has
a right to a kid nobody has a
fundamental right to be a parent
you have parental rights but you don't
have a right to become a parent in the
first place the world doesn't owe you
that is what i'm saying
and the problem with surrogacy is that
you're commodifying the female body and
human life itself i mean you're
literally renting out a womb and and
you're buying eggs and
treating all these things like
commodities and
i think the female body and human life
should be treated with more dignity than
that
you know at the daily wire we've started
our own publishing wing called dw books
i had the honor to be the first book
that we published with johnny the walrus
but we're proud to publish many more and
these are books that actively fight the
left's monopoly on storytelling like
fiery but mostly peaceful the 2020 riots
and the gaslighting of america by julio
rosas who pulls back the curtain on the
black lives matter riots that broke out
across the country in the aftermath of
george floyd's death rosus who was
reporting from the ground gives his
first hand experience and exposes the
media's attempts to convince americans
that the fatal and destructive riots
were peaceful the book is available for
pre-order on amazon or anywhere you buy
books online so go pre-order your copy
today
also you know our product team is
currently searching for a director of
customer experience to lead our audience
experience teams in nashville this
person will work closely with our vice
president of operations to strategize
and implement innovative ways of
optimizing our audience experience
strategy to achieve business goals
strengthen our brand and provide optimal
value to the daily wired community
especially our subscriber base
what does any of that mean if that made
sense to you then you might be a
candidate for this job this is a unique
opportunity for a senior level customer
service professional with a passion and
skill for leadership and entrepreneurial
spirit and deep operational knowledge
and experience in all aspects of online
community management customer experience
and event attendance experiences to
apply for this opportunity and to view a
full list of our current openings of
daily wire visit dailywire.com careers
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well adhd has been back in the news
first with a salon article documenting
how a stark rise in adhd diagnoses seem
to mysteriously coincide with millions
of kids being locked inside for a year
and forced to take classes on zoom this
is something i've been you know
following for a while and we've talked
about before meanwhile the today show
ran a piece about the rise of adhd in
women especially mothers so adhd is all
over the place it seems it's also become
a profitable business to put it mildly
billions and billions of dollars have
been made and will be made on it
some companies as new york post reported
just last week have gotten more creative
in their marketing of adhd drugs with uh
ritalin ads now appearing on places like
tiktok
now
we know that psychiatric industry and
big pharma have set out to catalog and
medicalize virtually every human
behavior emotion inclination and
personality trait soon nobody in america
will be considered normal
you wonder where the drug companies and
psychiatrists get their idea of normal
behavior and normal brains and normal
emotions considering they so rarely come
across a behavior brain or emotion they
consider normal we'll pick that thread
back up in a minute but first let's
acknowledge
that nowhere is this tendency to
medicalize the human condition more
apparent or more dangerous than with
children there's been an astounding rise
in adhd diagnosis stretching back not
just through covet but for decades
before that somewhere around 10 of all
children in the country have been
labeled with this alleged disorder
before the lockdown
and the labels being stuck on kids at
earlier and earlier ages we're now told
that kids as young as two years old
can be diagnosed adhd a third of kids
with adhd are diagnosed before the age
of six
doctors will assure parents that the
drugs are safe and will cause no
long-term damage to their children but
at best we don't actually really know
whether that's fully true or not there's
plenty of reason to believe that the
drugs could be
affecting your child's brain for years
to come and on what basis have we taken
this incredible step as a society to
drug into oblivion what used to be
considered common childhood
characteristics after all any
experienced parent will recognize the
list of adhd symptoms as the most normal
characteristics in the world
those symptoms if you look it up
include
in constant motion squirms and fidgets
makes careless mistakes often loses
things does not seem to listen easily
distracted does not finish tasks
now frankly i would be more concerned
about a child who doesn't exhibit these
symptoms
so
symptoms quote unquote so how can we
know when normal childhood behaviors may
be a manifestation of mental illness
it's quite easy to know when your liver
kidney or heart are malfunctioning but
with adhd and so many other mental
illnesses pediatricians and
psychiatrists claim to have identified a
malfunction of the whole human person
now it's non-controversial to look at a
diseased liver and say a liver shouldn't
do that
it's functioning wrong
but doctors are now looking at
physically healthy children and saying
this entire person shouldn't be doing
that they shouldn't be acting like that
on what basis
well the mayo clinic explains it says in
general a child shouldn't receive a
diagnosis of attention deficit disorder
unless the core symptoms of adhd start
early in life before the age of 12 and
create significant problems at home and
at school on an ongoing basis
so according to the medical community a
child's personality becomes diseased at
the precise moment
that his personality interferes with his
schooling
that's odd isn't it because physical
diseases aren't judged that way if you
go to the doctor because you think you
have appendicitis he's not going to ask
if the appendicitis is causing problems
at home or school appendicitis is
appendicitis no matter how convenient or
inconvenient it may be to those around
you
appendicitis is appendicitis at school
at home
uh even if you're walking alone you know
down a path in the forest
but adhd
is not adhd depending on the context
it's only when it's a nuisance that it
becomes
adhd
now this diagnostic criteria is rather
peculiar especially because advocates
for adhd drugs will claim that the
disorder can be located in the brain
but if it can be located in the brain
why is it diagnosed with a personality
survey instead of a brain scan has
anyone ever stopped to ask that question
now it may be true that you can find
certain neurological similarities among
certain people who have been diagnosed
with adhd
but you could find neurological
similarities among people with any with
any kind of shared disposition such as
like enthusiasm or altruism you could
find neurological similarities among
optimists and among pessimists
that doesn't prove that these
similarities cause optimism or
enthusiasm or hyperactivity in children
you could look at the brain scan of a
man grieving his dead wife and see his
grief reflected in his brain
you could also see his happiness at the
birth of a child you could see the you
know the experience he has in prayer i
mean all of that you can you can see
reflected in the brain
but that doesn't prove that the chemical
reactions in his brain are causing those
things
a guy who's happy
does his brain look like that because
he's happy or is he happy because his
brain looks like that that's a chicken
or egg question we never seem to bother
asking
now of course if you take an entirely
materialistic view of the human person
which catastrophically many
psychiatrists do
then you must believe that everything he
feels everything a a man thinks all of
his traits his characteristics his flaws
his desires his goals his joy his love
his despair and so on are all just
material phenomena
the mind is an illusion in that case
you're just your brain and nothing more
but if on the other hand you factor in
the soul and free will and the
uniqueness of each human person who's
created by a divine force it becomes
clear
that the mind exists and it drives the
brain much more than the brain drives it
but even if we put all that to the side
and i don't really see how you can put
it to the side because this chicken or
egg problem lies at the very heart of
the entire psychiatry industry in
everything we think about mental illness
but even if you do
and even if you accept just for a moment
that brain chemistry determines
everything about a person
that still wouldn't prove that any
particular personality like the adhd
personality is disordered
it doesn't prove in other words that a
person isn't supposed to be that way
it also doesn't prove that the brain
itself is causing this disorder if it is
a disorder at all
now this brings us back to the thread we
started pulling
at the start
you know i've talked before about kids
at adhd
made many of these points but as
mentioned this adhd epidemic stretches
beyond childhood
many of the diagnosed kids are adults
today and many adults who were never
diagnosed are being diagnosed now which
is no surprise because it's really easy
to be diagnosed with adhd as i said they
don't diagnose it by looking at your
brain they diagnose it by asking you
questions about
what you do and how you feel and how you
act
but it's especially true now because all
of us
are distracted and unable to pay
attention to anything for very long all
of us
this is a phenomenon stretching across
the entire civilized world
it's been well documented
many entire books have been written
about including one i'm reading right
now called stolen focus by johann hari
in that book which i recommend
hari offers extensive documentation of
the many measurable ways in which our
collective attention spans have dwindled
and there are a lot of of of things
telling this story you know we read
fewer books a lot fewer we retain less
information we feel the need to
constantly switch tasks we're obsessed
with what we call multitasking
though as the book explains multitasking
is a myth for humans multitasking is
actually a word that first applied to
computers
and now we talk about it like people do
it but really your brain you know you
can't do two things at once you can
rather switch quickly between tasks
which is what we're all of us are doing
all the time the modern world is set up
this way
and of course the number one indication
of this problem and also the number one
cause
is the phone that we all carry around
with us and check hundreds of times a
day throughout the day even if there's
no reason to be checking it we just
compulsively pick it up and check it
it's not like we're focusing intently on
any of the content that we encounter on
the phone
either
i mean the average user spends mere
seconds on each webpage he visits
when it comes to news articles many
people only read the headline and don't
get beyond that on social media like
twitter of course there's an endless
scroll of content in little bite-sized
chunks that each takes five seconds or
less to consume so we're all distracted
we're all suffering extreme attention
laws
even our memories have been negatively
impacted
this this is an effect that's aptly been
dubbed uh digital dementia
now this is all by design of course
there are very powerful forces at work
or very good at seizing hold of your
attention and diverting it from one
thing to the next
your attention is a resource
and they seek to claim it and monetize
it and they have
it's not just the phone this problem
exists existed before smartphones it's
just that smartphones are such effective
vehicles for this kind of distraction
and there are extremely complicated and
sophisticated algorithms personalized to
each one of us designed to keep us
distracted but even outside of
cyberspace everywhere else you look in
the world you come up against a
never-ending barrage of distractions so
the question
in a world
where everything is literally designed
to distract us
and everyone is distracted all the time
how can the psychiatric industry come
along and declare that some of this
distractedness is a mental disorder
based on what
if i can pay attention to something for
10 seconds and you can only pay
attention for seven
does that mean that you have adhd so we
establish an attention span baseline and
whoever's below it is automatically
mentally ill
even if the baseline itself is dropping
which proves that the attention problem
is largely environmental
how does that make sense
telling people they have a mental
illness because they struggle to focus
in our society when they're constantly
bombarded with lights and sounds and
images and texts and noises and messages
of all kinds all the time non-stop
it's like telling people in a country
with a fast food restaurant on every
corner that their obesity is the result
of a disease which come to think of it
is exactly what we tell obese people
i'm starting to sense a pattern here
though i can't follow the trail for very
long because i get distracted
pharmaceutical industry would tell me
that that's because i'm mentally ill but
i could see a different cause
it's all around me
it's all around you
that's why ultimately i think the
pharmaceutical industry
must be the one
that is in the end cancelled
if you could pay attention to anything i
just said we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
josh hawley exposes supreme court
nominee katanji jackson's radical record
at her confirmation hearings kamala
harris babbles about the passage of time
and a january 6th protester faces 20
years in prison for trespassing after
cops let him into the capital check it
out on the michael knowles show